hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be looking at game 5 from the match of
the century 1972 Wood Chess Championship
between Bobby Fischer and buddy Spassky
now Spassky does have a game advantage
and he does have the white pieces who's
going to be looking to extend his lead
Bobby Fischer looking to continue to
play dominant with the black pieces and
even this series up
Spassky starts out with pawn to d4
Knight f6 from Bobby Fischer Spassky c4
pawn e6 Knight c3 and then Bishop down
here before getting into the
nimzo-indian offense we don't see the
nihms o as much mostly because b when
white side don't like to have the double
pawn structure on the queenside so you
know more nowadays we're seeing this
Knight to f3 that sort of early move but
Knight to c3 Bishop down b4 was very
common back in the day now white
continues Knight f3 pawn to c5
protecting this Bishop usually a bad
idea to take the bishop comes back here
Black's controlling the center of the
board White's giving up a central pawn
not really how you want to go Bobby
Fischer also has the luxury of playing
pawn to d6 pawn d5 he plays d6 you can
always push forward with pawn to e5 so
does leave him some options but first
starting with pawn to c5 with a nice
little outpost here on b4 and then
you're ready to push with his Knight to
c6 pawn to e3 just solidifying the pawn
chain knight c6 Bishop here d3 let me
get into a variation which we don't see
all that often nowadays but Bobby
Fischer definitely like to play it as
the bishop takes on c3 and the pawn
recaptures now Bobby Fischer's going to
be looking to play pawn to d6 pushing
forward with pawn to e5 are really
trying to break up the center of the
board now white really would like to
counter this with his own pond pushing
forward pawn to f4 usually preferred but
his knight on f3 although it's a
development move early on it actually
gets in the way of what he wants to do
right now also Spassky on the Queen side
he can't do too much he has double pawns
here on the C file so we can't really
extend like you would want to this
specific variation is one of the main
reasons why people just don't
like to play the nimzo-indian as white
because they get these double pawns here
and then they're kind of at the mercy of
their opponents kind of clogs the center
of the board it's just not the way that
people like to play when they're playing
that pawn to d4 early on into the game
so usually you're seeing more the knight
to f3 early on and then they can extend
on the Queen side which they usually
like to do but from here there's two
variations that white can go from here
he could first start with a castle on
the Kings side he five as we talked
about then Knight to d2 castle and then
d5 that's one option
Spassky chose the other option which is
pawn to e4 and then after pawn e5 as we
talked about now just push forward with
d5 four go castle on the King side for
right now this night it's going to come
back here to e7 and then White has a few
options usually you're going to see
Knight to d2 coming back here to f1
potentially coming to e3 or g3 so that
they can come to this outpost here on f5
now that's a lot of moves to kind of get
to this outpost right here Spassky
decides to go ahead and fast-track that
and play just Knight to h4 so we can
come here very quickly if he wants to
now pawn to h6 and then pawn f4 I think
this is a little aggressive from Spassky
I give what he's trying to do here just
trying to break up the center of the
board but I would rather just play
castle on the Kings side just wait see
what your opponent does then you can
push forward with pawn to f4 the moves
not going anywhere but your opponent
could after pawn to f4 blow things up he
could play Bishop down here to g4 right
away which I really like I think this is
a great move stops the castling on the
Kings side right away I could decide to
go ahead and take right now I think
you're not going to be Castle you're
going to be taking back with your bishop
or in this particular spot Bobby Fischer
plays Knight to g6 this those are wrench
in the whole plan so right away I do
think the pawn to f4 probably a little
ambitious from buddy Spassky Spassky
continues Knight takes on g6 pawn takes
now the pawn takes on e5 I would use to
capture here
Bishop up here to e3 upon b6
just solidifying this Fontaine the
bishop was attacking the pawn here on c5
also wants to open up the door for his
light-square bishop to get involved into
the game now we see a castle on the
kingside cast on the Kings side for
black and then pawn to a Ford have to
kind of look at it both sides of the
board they have equal material we do see
a double pawn here on the G file for
black I don't mind that too much it does
open up the door for the rook to kind of
control this white on the opposite side
has double pawns here on the C file you
know that's fine as well what I like
more about Bobby Fischer's position is
he has a knight it seems kind of small
on the surface but these bishops are
going to be doing too much with the klog
center of the board they just can't
control much of the board this Knight
can hop over anywhere he wants to go
there's a nice outpost here on f4 if you
can get to it that's going to be very
very dangerous it's just going to be
very difficult for white to really take
this position and turn it into anything
really that great so all in all I think
it's very draws position on board but I
do like black position a little bit more
from here we do see pawn to a5 just
stopping the push here on a4 you never
want your opponent to start pushing up
on your Queen side we're here to be one
attacking the backward pawn here on b6
it is kind of a pain to have to worry
about protecting that but he does have
the Queen right here on d8 first we see
Bishop to d7 attacking the pawn right
here and a for the Queen is protecting
this but doesn't need to make sure that
he holds on to that material first rook
up here to b2 now rook b8 he can now get
his queen involved into the game not
have to worry about protecting the pawn
here on b6 work over here f2 Queeny 7
Bishop back c2 so now he can get his
Queen involved into the game not have to
worry about protecting the pawn over
here on a4
pawn g5 so this double pawn here can
actually start pushing forward whereas
you kind of see this double pawn here
for White's it's kind of stuck here it's
not doing anything can't push forward
here where Bobby Fischer can start to
actually put a lot of pressure with his
double pawns on the Kings side
Spassky Bishop back here d2 Queeny AIT's
a bishop back II one Queen to g6
threatening this pawn here on e4
so Bobby Fischer does have an attack
here this Bishop on c2 is somewhat
overloaded it's defending both the pawn
here on a4 and here on e4 so Bobby
Fischer can start to kind of attack that
weakness now queen up here d3 does add
another protection layer on the square
here on e4 Knight over here h5 rook
takes rook takes would you see the
exchange on board which i think is
better for Bobby Fischer because both
sides it's neither side was really going
to do too much but Spassky had a lot of
pieces in place to defend properly it's
going to be very difficult for Bobby
Fischer to kind of break through and do
anything because you got two rooks back
here two bishops everything seemed fine
for Spassky to defend but after Bishop
to d1 you can really tell that white is
in full on I'm in defend mode any if
your bishops are on the first rank when
you are 26 moves in for white you're not
looking to win the game you're looking
to just for any attack that comes
through but this is just really bad
these bishops are really just
controlling the sides of the board
they're not controlling the center of
the board which is where Bobby Fischer
can start to attack here so not really a
good game plan if they were on Bishop on
d2 and Bishop on e 2 as well that's a
little bit better construct to control a
little bit more of the side and the
center of the board but on this first
rank that's very very poor but it's
still going to be difficult from Bobby
Fischer do anything but he starts out
with Knight to f4 probably his best a
you know chance to actually try to make
something happen
attacking the Queen right here he's
still attacking the pawn over here on a4
the bishop jack in this the bishops
still holding onto it and then from here
we see buddy Spassky make up into this
point the worst move so far now we're
only five games in so take that for what
it is but he makes a very very bad
choice and he plays Queen to c2 now he
was kind of looking at and says okay I
still need to be able to protect this
pawn on e4
the Queen comes down on e for
unprotected it's just lights out it's
just all bad news for white so he wants
to come back still protect this pawn on
a4 but but it was already protected
having with the Queen here is just not
the way he wants to go because Bishop to
a4 but these Spassky was actually forced
to resign after this move there's just
no way it's really hold on to it Bobby
Fischer does win Game five and they tie
up the series now we'll go through
sometimes I'll get asked in videos hey
how does this continue like why would
Betty Spassky in this particular spot
lose so we'll kind of walk through it
let's say the Queen takes right here
somewhat common now the Queen takes on
e4 and this is threatening mate Queen to
g2 mates the Queen is not going to be
able to get involved into the action and
save anything so all in all it's just a
matter of do we hold on for more move so
Queen up here eh yeah we're just
sacrificing moves so that we don't get
checkmated right away everything else is
you're going to lose right away it's
just all bad news from here so Queen e8
you know takes the bishop here check all
of a sudden we kind of move around and
at the end of the day we're just going
to have a checkmate there's no way for
white to hold on now if we come back and
say okay after Bishop takes on a4 well
let's say that Queen to d2 will give up
that pond that's fine
but we don't want to lose the game so
Queen to d2 Bishop takes the Queen now
is forced to come to d1 but then the e4
pawn falls this is going to be bad Queen
to d2 got to protect that
checkmate here on g2 but now we get to
see the knight takes on g2 this is just
really bad the Queen can't really take
because then the bishops going to fall
check just going to gobble up more
material here on c3 that's going to be
bad if we try to get creative Bishop up
here g3 since it is being attacked then
all of a sudden Knight here to eat three
there's just no way that White's really
able to defend this Queen f2 check King
e7 that's fine
pawn h3 start to just gobble up material
the pawn here on C
was going to f----- all of a sudden we
have three pawns from whites we have
seven ponds from black black is all up
in white side of the board and you can
just start to gobble up more this
material a white on the other kink
really can't move it is as soon as he
moves this bishop can't get involved as
soon as movies as Queen just going to
lose more material so these pesky looked
at and said alright that was a terrible
mistake with Queens - see - I just have
to resign in this position now keep in
mind if we come back one move if you to
play just Queen to be one this is fine
he still needs to hold on to e4 which is
the most critical square on the board
but he's still holding down the fort on
a4 with his bishop which is really what
he needs to do but he did miss that play
Queen to see - it's crazy just this once
little move allowed Bobby Fischer to
come in and immediately win the game in
a position that was probably drawn I
mean I would imagine in just a few more
moves they would have shaken hands and
gone to the next game but he's fast he
would have still been up a game so all
in all terrific game from Bobby Fischer
what's interesting is after the game
after they've tied this Bobby Fischer
went to his his second which is kind of
his coach his sidekick during these
matches Bill Lombardi they actually told
him hey I've got a surprise coming up
for Game six so just get ready for it
which can only imagine what Bobby
Fischer means by that so that's going to
be pretty exciting if you're not too
familiar with Game six make sure you
look out for that video it's going to be
good one but thank you guys for tuning
in for Game five
it's definitely a good one series even
up at two and a half points each I'll
see you guys in the next one